we begin with breaking news a new a new
package explosion overnight in Texas
this time was that a FedEx facility
outside San Antonio one person was
injured a law enforcement source says it
appears a package was mailed from Austin
and it was also due to be delivered to
Austin the blast went off at a FedEx
Ground facility in shirt's about an hour
from the state capitol the FBI says it's
more than possible the new explosion is
related to the recent bombings in Austin
four explosions have killed two people
and injured four others the latest was
Sunday night
Omar Villafranca is in shirt's near the
FedEx facility where the latest bomb
exploded Omar good morning good morning
we just learned that FBI and ATF agents
are on the scene behind me at this
facility they're going through some of
that bomb debris to see if there's any
matching components a signature that
would link this bomb with the four bombs
in austin austin's travis country
neighborhood was on lockdown monday as
investigators scoured the area for clues
the FBI is brought in over 350 special
agents to work here it's an
unprecedented response debris from
Sunday's blast stretched across an
entire Street a trip wire was used to
set off the explosion while police say
that's a significant change from the
first three targeted attacks interim
chief brian manly says the evidence
appears to be connected we're seeing
similarities between some of the
components that are used to construct
the device you can hear sunday's bomb
detonate in this home security video
we want all video because we would look
for similarities we would look for
connections we would look for anything
that might lead us to identifying the
suspect or suspects with no arrests and
the attacks continuing Austin Mayor
Steve Adler worries about his city what
do you do you can't tell population size
to stay inside until we catch this and
over what you can tell people is that
they should be vigilant during a press
conference Sunday afternoon Manly
directly addressed the bomber we want to
understand what brought you to this
point and we want to listen to you do
you think he's listening to police
clearly former counterterrorism agent
Fred Burton believes the attack Sunday
night was the Bombers response to man
Lee's appeal I think when the chief
asked for a message this was it this was
the message and he's one step ahead do
you believe this person is gonna strike
again I don't have a reason to believe
that they won't obviously we are
pleading that this come to an end if
federal agents are able to match this
bomb with the four bombs in Austin it
would basically be telling investigators
that this is the first time this
suspected bomber has tried to use a
delivery service to deliver a bombs the
first three that were in Austin were
dropped off the fourth one which
happened on Sunday was a tripwire so
this bomber could be changing methods
John Moore thanks yeah one day if it's
one bomber three different approaches
very frightening frightening